the coronavirus also struck the royal
family when Prince Charles fell ill and
yesterday the Queen took the rare step
of addressing the public about the
pandemic and we have the details of how
they kept her safe I'm speaking to you
at what I know is an increasingly
challenging time
Queen Elizabeth practiced social
distancing during her four minute speech
our royal source tells us there was only
one cameraman he wore a mask and gloves
and was positioned far enough away from
the 93 year old Queen today once again
many will feel a painful sense of
separation from their loved ones other
than her annual Christmas message this
was only the fifth time in her 68 year
reign that Elizabeth has addressed her
subjects including the death of Princess
Diana in 1997 we have only been trying
to help William and Harry no doubt Harry
watched his grandmother's speech from
his new home in LA where he's holed up
with Megan and Archie we're told Harry
quote misses his family he's been
staying in touch with his father and
loves his grandmother meanwhile Megan's
first post Meg's it gig just debuted the
new Disney nature documentary elephant
on the long road back to the Delta
Megan recorded her top secret voiceover
back in October at London's Pinewood
Studios and she wasn't alone we also had
Harry for the cheap seats suggesting
some alternative pronunciation there he
is
what is he doing the filmmakers think
this cute baby elephant reminded Megan
of our cheeks when she actually narrated
Archie was still just a wee lad
[Music]